and just like that we are back inside
the film room ready to learn from Chris
Simms big old brain in between weeks
three and weeks for what you know better
mood today
wait are you seriously on yeah you're
not in my ears or anything and there's
no music so you were perfectly talking
under the music that was unbelievable
the music was going on and you stopped
right as the Beecher on no idea
that's incredible literally landed that
perfectly I just saw I literally stopped
talking in the beat drop it was
incredible I got people coming up to me
at the office and saying you know it's
Chris okay yeah yeah okay good deal deal
with it the Chris likes to do his job
when Chris can't do his job he gets
pissed off it was a big week we had some
cool stuff for the show which you guys
will see later we hung out with some New
York Jets we played some games I hope
you guys checked out the new episode of
Sims and left go the show
Wednesday night it's on YouTube right
now check it out we the last episode we
welcomed a new informant we learned a
lot about Bill Belichick and who is this
informer I don't know but a tantalizing
obsession with saltwater taffy maybe
that's the reason the Patriots are
losing we also got to do sac face which
is a lot of fun and we hung out with
DeMarco Murray and Chad Johnson so make
sure you check that out
Sims the left go the show but yeah yeah
auntie oh but I want to do some quick
announcements we have a little it's kind
of a gift for the Simpson left go
faithful and mainly the people that are
in these Sims and left go fantasy league
Odell Rogers is now 2 & 1 by M so we
have Sims and left go fantasy league
shirts they are now on sale and it's we
have a deal for the 392 members of the
fantasy league but really it's open to
anybody
sneeze by Sims but mainly for the owners
we talked to bleacher report and we
wanted to make a gift for everybody we
want to get everybody a t-shirt and we
convinced bleacher report that we're
literally not going to make any money on
these shirts and we're
not going to charge any shipping and
handling Wow so we wondered ice we
wanted to give shirts to everybody in
the fantasy league at the exact cost
that we're paying for them
so it's gonna be $19 and I'm gonna give
you the website it is the Loyalists
dot-com /sl FL 2018 and he can pick out
whatever you want
loyalist comm / SL FL 2018 on the front
it will say SL FL and in the year and on
the back you picked the name of your
conference and your conference will be
on the back so somebody in our
conference wanted to get Lego the golden
spleen conference it will say on the
back so everyone that's in the SL FL
it'll be $19 and with the promo code
fantasy the shipping will only cost $3
so minor correction great speech left go
three dollars worth of shipping so it's
19 bucks for the shirt promo code
fantasy 23 bucks gets 22 stop
interrupting you said have a problem you
said original
yo yo shut up you have a problem I don't
have any problem
so it's $3 shipping and this is
everywhere in the world so so like even
the guy that's playing fantasy and Dubai
shipping is only gonna cost you $3 Wow
yes are you sure about that we're
hooking it up I think he's talking out
of his ass this is true this is on the
scrap okay so loyalists calm /s LFL 2018
if you guys are not in the league but
you want a shirt and you there's a
certain conference that you think is
funny go ahead and buy it the promo code
works for you one note we did have a
conference called the Earthsea Irsay's
oxys conference all right can't put that
on my shirt or a company okay I can't be
that crazy so what's the name of it now
the RSA Conference the Earth's a
conference well done yeah so we had to
do that but yeah the shirts are out
there the Loyalists comm /s LFL 2018 we
took care of all the [ __ ] costs you
get it at cost it's kind of a gift for
us to you if you want to represent your
fantasy team out there in the world
Teemo del Rodgers we are 2 & 1 & our new
quarterback Sims which image e going
down
Tannehill okay I'll take that you'll
take time I'll take it yep three dollars
for Dubai shipping I'm still caught up
on that that's pretty amazing you should
be not all the shirts are going to Dubai
I know one of them yes we have one guy
that listens we have a guy yeah he
listens to me people are literally all
over the place Ceylon Canada Australia
these shirts are going everywhere I'm
afraid to go to Dubai why is that
because like people have been like
arrested and thrown in jail for fighting
like a speck of marijuana in their
luggage like that scares me by the way I
didn't I didn't tell you guys an issue
well something that could anything that
way I didn't tell you guys but I made
some moves too I picked up Darren
Sproles Jalen Rashard and Haden Hurst I
think okay what are your thoughts I
picked up Haden Hurst because I go this
is a first-round pick and he's coming
back from injury I'm sure they're gonna
weave him back into the offense yeah
it's not like Rickey seals Jones has
been killing it France yeah and Jalen
Rashard and Darren Sproles I went Darren
Sproles got a lot of touches that first
game yeah maybe they'll weave them in
and the wide receivers aren't that good
I just picked some guys up okay that's
good I haven't really been communicating
that guy's your thing but we're two and
one we're being carried by Phelan Odell
and juju I like that the three-headed
monster wide receivers has been perfect
Oreo cookie style and AHS awesome I'm so
glad that that's that way more
announcements shout out to the DMS I'm
gonna be honest
vendrick and I we had a DN that said
your social media manager should be paid
more our social media manager is
vendrick and Lefko but we got a little
bit behind in the DMS so we haven't been
able to get to we have about like I
don't know 150 in there right now
but I want you to know that even if we
don't get to all of them keep sending
them we use that to kind of figure out
more about the show we would everyone
yeah what you guys want to see what you
don't want to see we care about you guys
more than anything same thing going for
YouTube comments we've put on there what
film would you like to see Sims talk
about so we're going to make sure we do
the Dolphins later because there was a
number of people that said how are the
Dolphins three-and-oh
that will be something I think we do in
the future where the Monday show we put
out there which what what do you want to
see and if we don't touch it on the
Monday show yeah it'll be what please
and requests yeah please tell me what to
watch I would like to know to the order
in which to do it yeah it is and then
the ovens are fun
fascinating team oh they really are they
kind of remind me a little bit of the
Bucks where they've score a lot on big
plays and I don't know how consistent
that is in the long term right but I
will say that I like what Munk ins doing
I think that's his name for Tampa Bay
offensive coordinator and Wow
Adam GaSe can coach a team without
Jarvis Landry and and Dalma can soothe
an so crazy I wonder if there was any
podcast that even put their hard-earned
dollars on the Dolphins going over a
seven-game wins yes and then federic
wrote in that survivors back tears
tonight on CBS awesome I'll be doing
fantasy league updates on Twitter if
anyone wants to watch anything but that
I'm surprised you read that I just put
that in there to see if you'd read it
figure dude where's where they happen
where what island are they so I don't
even know they don't they don't play out
the location any well they don't think
there is survivor this year is in
Zimbabwe well put a bow put a boat
butter and then they show like a zebra
and they're like it's gonna be the
wildest survivor yet this session Disney
World Space Mountain has ever been to
survivor cast members that have gotten
married yeah Robin amber oh yeah that
was very way early on they did amazing
race together too
has there ever been like issue of a lot
of sex oh I don't know about a lot but
Robin amber was definitely a very heavy
who's the most famous former survivor
contestant I mean Richard Hatch maker's
winner went to jail yeah for what I
think tax evasion
he's probably mean and then no one's
really saying a winner a winner no any
but oh well Jimmy Johnson was on there I
mean there Ben Culpepper was on ever
been football players I am Brad
Culpepper Culpepper did it with his wife
oh they did so I could see that they did
the blood versus water season where they
were on different tribes and they came
together oh I could see that he was like
a crazy survivor Monica he's crazy I
think one is that right yeah they're
crazy there was always a lot of crazy
stories about them and Tampa actually we
should do that at some point well if
you're not excited by that conversation
you may be excited to learn that Atlanta
Oh Super Bowl week tell us more laughs
go I'm just gonna say that we are
planning on probably having just like we
normally do on Superbowl radio row like
50 to 70 guests and
think we're gonna be doing shows pretty
much Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday a
Super Bowl week and I think we're gonna
have our own little place that's only
ours and there's not going to be media
credentials and in between the shoots
maybe you're gonna hang out with us and
maybe we do live shows where we only
talk to the podcast listeners that show
up maybe we have exclusive stuff that we
don't even put out maybe you get to go
holy crap they're interviewing von
Miller two feet in front of me it's all
possible you don't even have to go to
the game Atlanta Super Bowl week little
birdies in my ear
correction Monica came in second place
she did not win that okay good thank you
for clearing that up Sims can you
believe that sports by Brookes tweeted
today I'm pretty shocked right yeah yeah
I mean him tweeting sports five Brookes
is big-time I mean it's been five years
damn that's a long time yeah I mean I
know used to read his stuff all the time
all the time I mean you know me and what
are the things they win over the most
from sports Oh hidden just yelling so
there's this guy his name is sports by
Brookes okay nobody really knows who he
is
IFT commenter in 2010 gotcha but like
yeah 2010 like he was as reputable
online as Schefter like sports by
Brookes would like break things all the
time and out of nowhere like Mario
things yeah Wow people would go to his
blog all the time he was like Mike
Florio like that's like he was like my
floor but for all we don't know who he
looks like or anything here's one
picture and that's all we've seen and
for the first time in five years he
tweeted today like there were a lot of
people that would write articles where
did sports friburgo that's his account
and he tweeted in 2013 right here
November 11th and then he hasn't tweeted
again until today yeah so these are the
internet stories that you have no idea
huge deal on Twitter today like how
every something good for the first time
I thought tweeted the video of Willy
Wonka emerging from his factory when he
pretended that he had a cane and then
rolled which to me is him being like I'm
back hmm which is very interesting or
he's about to abduct kids and throw them
into chocolate ponds that's that's very
possible as possible did you like Willy
Wonka the movie it was okay it's like
weird and trippy it's cool
in some places they kind of like
depressing and weird I just wanted the
entire binge-watch of maniac with Jonah
Hill on Netflix talk about weird and
trippy that's a show it was like a show
series Netflix you don't have Netflix I
do oh you do on every TV yep oh excuse
me of course
okay Apple yes all right I got some
random numbers for you number one Sims
yeah that's the amount of three and out
drives that the Rams have had the season
yeah it's I mean I don't know how much
you've read through my notes or whatever
but the question in the NFL right now is
what is a more unstoppable force right
now the Rams offense or the Chiefs
offense Rams are they're unbelievable I
don't even know what to say Shaun Shaun
McVeigh is unbelievable is not a given
that right now or what is Shaun McVeigh
yeah the best offensive coordinator in
the NFL right now I think he is right
now
I do because a lot of people will go no
duh it's sean mccabe right but I know in
your mind it's typically a foursome yeah
Sean Payton Sean McVeigh Kyle Shanahan
Josh McDaniel I do look at them as
playing a step up and there are a little
interchange of right
and there's the Nagy's and all that
stuff right but you're mine right now
McVeigh is number one mugged McVeigh is
number one right now yes and I and one
of the things I wrote in my notes and I
don't know if I'm gonna get to it is
that okay if we talk about this okay is
that is that I wrote in about McVeigh I
go he doesn't have like like Kyle
Shanahan's the best play action guy of
the group right here there's nobody he's
nobody comes up with more ways and play
action josh mcdaniels is the best drop
back I'm gonna find little waste in the
short passing game to just be surgical
and drive you crazy wide receiver
screens on the outside the Edelman plays
all of that make you feel almost helped
right Sean Payton's like the best that
may be drawn up shots for touchdowns
like absol you know what I mean like
here's I got these plays I don't want
you to throw a long haul game until I
call this play and he'll be back I don't
think about the Willie Snead balm in the
NFC divisional game that he just missed
thrown it was that perfect shot exactly
right so there's always those and then
McVeigh is like not the best at any of
them but maybe second and third of all
of them and then added to the fact like
his screen game I call say
The Scream game I think the best screen
game in football right now is the
Jacksonville Jaguars I'm Nate Hackett
and what he does but yeah McVeigh
there's no weakness to his office he
doesn't have one area where I look at if
he was a little bit more of a creative
play caller in this department right
they would be unstoppable and and the
game the other day was the perfect
example
I mean speed sweep was the theme of the
game like you know what I mean by the
speed sweep or like he's underneath the
center and Robert Woods flies by he had
he had like three or four of those that
were yeah he had those but it's what he
has off of it that is where you just go
this is what's blowing this defense away
and that's where I become important you
mean like a quarter later they fake the
Suites so were they by doing like four
plays in a row and they go here's the
speed sweep here's the fake speed sweep
and the pulling guard and Todd Gurley
runs down here's the speed sweep and
fake the pulling guard and we toss it
out the backdoor to Todd Gurley here's
the speed sweep fake to Todd Gurley
screen to Todd Gurley here's the
play-action pass with a deep post over
the top of the speed sweep at the fake
town and so his tree of yes ammunition
off of one concept that's what always
amazed and the fact that he has an
offense now with Brandon cooks yeah
where cooks woods and Gurley are gonna
outrun most defenders so you have three
weapons Cooper Cup is a great receiver
right but now he has cooks yeah and
cooks really is like what they always
want to tape on Austin exactly right he
is more polished good receiver has no
weakness to his game can do it all I
think that's right look at it it's
already been in Sean Payton's offense
and Josh McDaniels actually I mean
Brandon cooks has literally the greatest
offense of coaching track record of any
player in the NFL it's amazing and I
think this guy's using his skillset
better than anybody I know why Xiaomi
face the best yeah something happened
after the Cleveland Jets game that it
upset me and it's coming back into my
mind right now okay
Cleveland finally gets their first win
yeah Hugh Jackson takes the podium
beyond the fact that he didn't name
Baker the starter I asked but I actually
I got it it's right after the game out
of all due respect to Tyrell whatever
you know what upset me what he was
offended that someone said you ran
Philly you're you're right that was me
let me finish yes
I'll shut up progress unbelievable he
was offended that someone would say that
he stole Philly Philly
I believe his quote was something to the
effect of if you looked at my extensive
play history and Tod Haley's extensive
play history look we've had that play to
Sean McVeigh will actively tell you that
he's stealing place from people if if I
have an egotistical coach that can't
even say I really like that scheme it
reminded me of some Milam of the past I
can do it then your offense will remain
the same stale offense it always has
been yeah it's the same thing with all
thought leaders every thought leader
will tell you be a child always ask
questions never think you're the
smartest person in the room right it's
why Sean McVeigh's been so successful
there's he's not afraid of going I'm 32
years old I can learn from people yeah
I'm gonna go sit on the cooler and
actually do like organize my offensive
thoughts and let Wade coach he came out
this week and admitted that Jed fish is
his play clock specialist then he has a
coach that only watches certain times of
the clock and is an extra voice to go
hey be aware clocks running down below
blah blah blah a lot of coaches don't
want to share any of this right and they
run their offense yeah we have to
convince Michael McCoy to have David
Johnson play a little wide receiver but
I hear Hugh Jackson be too prideful to
admit that maybe it was from
Philadelphia and here we are talking
about Sean McVeigh that goes every
playbook is my playbook it's the coach I
want I know I hear yeah I don't know why
like there's just better ways to answer
that with you I don't know why he's
gonna answer not good diplomatic ly and
been like you know we a Philly's not the
first team to do that I mean they made
it famous we know that but we've had
this play whatever just say something
like that instead of being like like
you're saying oh no how dare you they
stole it from me I mean that but I think
your point about McVeigh too
that's what I find refreshing about him
there's no of the like why waste yeah
why waste your energy on oh I have to
hide who my clock-watcher is like
everybody else in football like come on
I'm just I'm over that crap all the time
you know even like dirt cutter this week
Dirk we'd know Ryan Fitzpatrick starting
well what are you like pandering about
come on like the Bears aren't going holy
[ __ ] they tricked us it's it's Jameis
rip up the game plan the offense is
changing we're screwed
I have a fun quote I know Mike Evans
said that at halftime they're down 20
points yeah Ryan Fitzpatrick looks at
Mike Evans are down 20 and he goes for
some odd reason I love [ __ ] football
I love it and evidence said he looked at
him and said I'm with you I love it too
Fitzpatrick use yeah I feel like
Fitzpatrick is the the other let you
remember the Wrangler commercials with
Brett Favre yeah I feel like Fitzpatrick
would be the quarterback on the other
team like he's just happy to be there
he's having a good time and yeah he's
ball until I mean he's making a lot of
big-time plays and I'm his voice I did
not I've been Ryan Fitzpatrick voice for
the three years of gridiron Heights
yeah I thought it was gonna end three
years ago and they're like hey left go
we got a whole episode about Ryan
Fitzpatrick I thought this was over
it's amazing we've done that many
episodes of gridiron Heights with
Patrick in it because I did a great
character I did one it was like season
two or it was like the the the worn out
QB lounge right and like I was a
bartender as Ryan Fitzpatrick an he goes
uh intercepted by the ground like we
were making it fun of how bad he is and
now he's this guy
I got another number for you yes third
time like numbers 13 13 yep did I get
any hit in here
let's take a guess 13 Dan Marino 13
that's how many touchdowns Patrick
mahomes has thrown thus far dan I was
too easy and your career games right
meaning according to Matt Bukowski that
mahomes has more career touchdowns than
Chris Sims in four games and really
three you ought to count that count that
last mop-up duty game he had yeah yeah
what did I have 12 12 damn 1217 what a
sorry
damn I went into that year with 12 and
11 or 11 and 10
and my spleen yes man I had I hate
listen I threw some dumb nurse this is a
random question you've talked before
about UC quarterbacks out there and you
go man I'm better than them this sucks
when you see a guy like Patrick mahomes
do you go oh I could have never been
that good yeah that's another level a
guy I had a chance to be special I'll
say that much but no he is and maybe you
asked my dad this then maybe he'd be the
better person that they actually
answered this question but no mahomes
mahomes arm I think even for me and my
prime I would be like man damn I might
be able to throw it that hard at times
and do all that but his ability just to
whip it in so many different angles
that's where it's special I mean he's
excites me like beyond belief when was
the first time after college that you
went on the field game practice and went
holy [ __ ] I'm not the strongest arm on
the field it actually never happened
until I know it really didn't it did not
happen and until the first guy I ever
had a sweat with and that whole thing
and this is another thing we could ask
my dad about was a guy at Texas named
chance mock who committed the Texas the
year after I got there LSU no no there
was a mock there as well yes but he was
like the number one quarterback in Texas
and stupidly committed there the year
after me I don't know what he was
thinking but chance he was the first
time I remember getting in like like
warm-ups and doing like running routes
vers air and throwing the ball and me
going like how [ __ ] dare you try to
throw the ball as hard as me and I
remember going like damn he could really
throw it holy cow let's start really
throwing it out here really yes but it
didn't really happen to me at the NFL
level until after my spleen and when I
went to Titans with like Kerry Collins
and Vince Kerry Collins had a cat he had
a candidate and Vince did to Vince Vince
might have not been always the most
polished passer and all that but I was
there going damn my arms not like pre
post injury not as special anymore
what's the best compliment you ever got
from Mack Brown hmm we had some good
times together
I don't know Chris I really like your
mouth yeah yeah things like that
yeah nothing special the best compliment
I ever got ever as a coach was from John
Gurdon and I still have the newspaper
article saved really the year I'd be
losing my spleen I mean I was killing
training camp that year like tearing
things up didn't even to the point where
I was like walking off the practice
field and being like man I was [ __ ]
awesome today like I tore our defense
apart and and I started knowing that the
rest of the team and the coaches were
wondering or realizing it too because
like the quarterback coach Paul Hackett
and Gruden when we watch practice they'd
be like I mean how did you make this
throw I mean what you threw it and he
was behind him and then you you knew he
like so that's when I was a kid they're
starting to realize it and he made a
comment to a newspaper article down
there that like they asked him about man
he's like his arm stronger than Favre's
it's stronger than Favre's i-i've been
in Green Bay his arm is stronger than
Favre's so there's an article in your
house yeah it's in my house I got a
framed where is it it's something like
my little daniels you know by shauna her
what's her yeah what the hell is that
repel the time where she watches her guy
she's got a crush on oh the trainer yeah
how much he likes Alex on pelletize I
like though that you said that Gruden
spoke to an article all right I got
another another random number for you
seriously yes six yes damn it's gonna be
something obvious again no okay
of the Patriots nine draft picks from
this past draft six are now on I are
with Chowan Bentley going on IR six of
their nine draft picks are on IR that's
scary do it well who else is on IR that
group do you have the list no no okay
but Duke Dawson that's the one I'm most
tempted to see it I don't even know what
the status of his ability is because I
really liked him coming out and they
need him at the cornerback position
badly right now but man six yes that's a
unbelievable number I know now you got
me looking yeah this sucks
yep good well I know this doesn't
include Rex Rex Burkhead
yep man it's alright it doesn't matter
he's not on the IR I know that
oh no way he is on IR yep he can't come
back for a little while all right I'm
gonna do this hey guys you enjoyed this
part of the podcast it's brought to you
by Simms Simms asked questions that
Lefko has to search for injured reserve
okay I think it's brought to you by left
Co gives us stats and doesn't have the
[ __ ] facts to back it up sorry for
the F word damn dukedom fire here early
I think I've done eight curved swords in
the first eight minutes alright Duke
Dawson Isiah win yes
Braxton Barrios native receiver right
from Miami I just said Juwan badly and
then I don't know if these guys were
rookies or not but Darren Andrews Cody
Hollister Alan Thicke Hollister is
Ullrich John Christian Sam Ryan is oh
they got they got eleven guys but some
difference makers there and I are that's
I mean guys that you know he's able to
find some of those draft picks but yeah
those were these some numbers news and
notes a keep Talib and Marcus Peters
both out for a month
am I wrong to say that Wade Phillips
defense revolves around the corner backs
a lot it doesn't not as much as you
would think they're he's smart as far as
not being an overly man-to-man I'm gonna
put this pressure on my guys from Denver
I know right I know it's a little
different that way now I think he he
specifically plays a little bit more
zone especially with guys like Donald
ensue in the middle because he just goes
why am I gonna give them the chance to
just throw it up real quick or throw a
back shoulder to where they can't create
some havoc at times which I don't think
they have a ton of sacks no Rams but
when you watch them there's a lot of HAP
quarterbacks are very uncomfortable all
the time it's always I got to throw the
ball now because I'm gonna get hit or so
how worried should Rams fans be that the
two corners that they're so excited
about are both gonna be out for like a
month
yeah I don't look at it as like a huge
game-changer that's kind no I know
because I think they're that good of a
football team I think that's the biggest
thing I think they can make do with what
they got there right they still got what
there are nickel Roby Coleman I think
one of the biggest signings of the
offseason and I had mad we haven't got
to this already but the Sam Shields
I mean sham Sam Shields was a good
player remember he got a concussion yeah
and then got another one and we
didn't hear from him for a year but he
was at the time you got a concussion he
was still a good football player and I
know you love their safety I do right
and they can they can pie some corner
too right like if needed by LaMarcus
Joyner was a corner in College of fart
of states so I think that's where I look
at it with there's still enough talent
on the defense yeah and he's a smart
enough guy to to formulate something new
for it for me if the Rams can lose both
of their starting quarterbacks and not
take a step back if you don't think it's
that big of a deal then what is gonna
make them take a step back
Oren Donald yeah something like that
right Aaron Donald some Todd Gurley
that'll change things Brendan cooks
would even change things at this point
because so much of the offense is
dictated as well through him I'm so wait
I I didn't even know all this I knew a
key was a month Marcus Peters they're
saying a month - I'm almost positive
because Marcus Peters I know earlier in
the week they thought if the game was
Sunday this week that there'd be a
chance he could actually play so it came
out that he could miss two to four weeks
okay with the chemistry all right I
didn't think they were overly overly
concerned with that one I think he'll be
more towards the two weeks speaking of
another team on Thursday night Everson
Griffin yeah that's going on right now
he's undergoing evaluation a local
hospital after battling a serious mental
health related issue for weeks there's a
ton of storylines I don't know what the
truth is there's yelling there's there's
claims of I'm gonna kill you at a hotel
yeah we didn't know why you missed the
game Buffalo it sounds like we're really
not gonna know for a while but this is
something you've been hearing about for
a while well I didn't hear about it for
a while but I just made a few phone
calls and yeah I think this has been
something that's on the Vikings radar
for the last few weeks to a month and it
finally came to a culmination point of
whatever disaster happened on Saturday
yeah so it's that's a shame and that's a
huge blow to that team you know so here
we are we lose two corners the Rams are
fine yeah
Vikings lose ever sinned Griffin what
does that do
III think that's a bigger loss than the
two corners being lost Rance yet because
I think so much has dictated about you
know
Minnesota's front for Zimmer is not a
guy that wants to really blitz he wants
to mess with your protections put the
two
and the a gaps of time so you have to
worry about them they drop out a lot
maybe one comes here and there but
Everson Griffin's ability for them to
okay we're gonna get in your face with
our first round corners and disrupt you
with the line of scrimmage and they're
gonna stay on you like glue plays into
okay well we're gonna have Everson come
off the edge and let him just fly around
there you know they have a little
different defensive philosophy than Wade
Phillips and and then also with a
Sheldon Richardson one-on-one and then
it just goes back to our whole thing of
we're concerned about their depth
overall as is like I have a hard time
believing Josh Allen would have had some
of those plays that he had last week
running the ball if that person Griffin
was out there it's a big drop-off Daniel
hunters a fine player the other kid they
play they're a lot of this chin is
ninety one Weatherly I'm think I'm
getting that right heave whether right
like another long solid player but not
special Everson Griffin makes their
defensive line special and that's where
I think it could hurt is it that he's
that good or it's game plan that it kind
of revolves her well it's it's he's that
good for that kind of defense to it's
just they're about getting up field
causing that havoc is no read it's just
this is your gap or go get the
quarterback and he comes around the edge
as good as anybody in football it's just
funny that I feel like common NFL fans
know to leave in Peters and their loss
isn't that big of a deal yeah and I
would say that Everson Griffin's
well-known yeah but I don't think he's
as well-known as to Libra Peters now and
yet his impact as one guy yeah might be
bigger than both of them being it did it
is and you know I think the other thing
it just goes to that is you know how
your rosters built and and the Rams have
a roster that's built perfectly for the
modern-day NFL I mean they have lots of
fast guys in the back end that mix up
how they want to play at safety or third
safety or nickel and they can do a lot
of different things there and the the
Vikings are are a team that's got a lot
of big money guys on the defensive side
of the ball and he's one of them but
they lack depth there and that's that's
gonna be an issue
other big news and I think this will be
an interesting conversation and we'll
see how much Sims can share Jimmy G
going down right they had a workout for
possible other quarterbacks
one of them was Matt Simms yes so I'm
kind of want Josh to participate this in
a lot because Josh wrote down a lot of
questions okay so do you mind if we just
ask you questions about how this process
works sure go ahead
okay so when Jimmy goes down yep
does Matt think in his head I could get
a call right now I think he wonders he
wondered for the reason I gonna cause me
to III did because Matt work was on the
practice squad with the Huggins practice
Lord of the Falcons right had the
training camp there then the year they
went to the Super Bowl he was on the
practice squad for that year so yeah
when he did go down I thought about it I
think he thought about it too but not
knowing where it would go from there
does Kyle calm at himself because they
have a prior relationship nope nope so
he doesn't hear from Kyle at all nobody
at all who calls I think it was a
personnel guy I'm not sure exactly who
it is he got a call basically like late
Monday night and they rely 24 hours
after 24 hours after to where they were
basically like can you get to Newark
Airport by not for a 9:30 flight and I
think they called it like 7 o'clock and
he was like what hold on and he threw
stuff in a bag and got there you have to
be ready to try out for an NFL team on
12 hours notice 12 hours notice take a
flight out there land at midnight West
Coast time which is gonna be 3:00 in the
morning you know East Coast time and
then get up and have a workout them
black night that night yeah so they did
the Tuesday 7 on Monday night and then
went there as the game he and then went
there Tuesday Tuesday for their little
private workout with all the
quarterbacks they had there who books
the travel who pays for it right that's
all the 49ers people that that Scouter
personnel guy he talks to tells them
they want to become the workout here's
the deal and then he from there most
likely goes you're gonna hear from our
secretary here in a minute she's gonna
call you from this number answer it and
she's gonna want to hear you know
first certain you know your birthday and
all that stuff so she can book the
flight so my big question list of
quarterbacks that tried out Kyle Allen
Kellen Clemens Matt Sims Tom savage TJ
Yates Landry Jones
manual right when that group is there
are they all hanging out in the locker
room before they go out and chit-chattin
and they are up yeah yeah you are you're
all of them like this little like you
know side locker room for the scrubs and
you're in there getting dressed and
they're basically like hairy guys get
dressed here's some gear to where they
give you gear more times than not right
and you put that on that Google have
somebody back out here in like 20
minutes and we'll bring you out to the
field let you guys get warmed up there
are some of them jerks and totally
locked in and they don't want to talk
and catch up or is it casual you could
be the most guys in the NFL are secure
with them themselves as a human being
that they can go okay I have to go out
here and be the best I can be and and
not worry about like putting the hex on
some other guy that's there yeah are
they watching each other yeah yeah
they're like taking turns from
everything I from everything I know and
at least the ones I've been a part of
yeah you're gonna throw see you good
it depends it's gonna be depending on
what they want to see or how much they
want to see so it can be different than
every kind of workout but I would
imagine they went through all the basics
of the route trees your slants your
hitches your curls your in cuts your
comebacks your go routes your post
routes deep cross maybe a tight end
route here or there so we talked in 75
throws I would say probably less than
that I would say like okay if they go
like all right everybody throw a curl
route you might get throw two or three
curl routes and then you're done and the
next guy has to go right so it's gonna
be like that check out a school trial
yeah pretty much
and then who's Kyle watch is he there
yes Kyle is there and yeah he watches
certainly especially with quarterback
stuff I mean because it's the office
it's just the offense and I think
anybody that's in need of a quarterback
the head coach is usually gonna be out
there for that type of workout
Kyle talked to any of them probably not
he probably lets these guys that run the
workout just let them run most teams
kind of have their formula for what they
like to do to have a workout done and
then as they get towards the end the guy
who runs the workout might look over at
Kyle anything else you want to see do
you want to you know anything else how
it might be oh yeah I want to see you
know for more play-action passes from
them or whatever they
like are we talking about like waking up
maybe a little bit earlier and getting a
workout in before you go no no it's
gonna be do you think Matt's like doing
push-ups being like a little bit more
muscle he is where he is at that point
so the push-ups are not gonna do it do
it
it's just get sleep get something to eat
and get ready to go and they might even
take you over there to let you eat
breakfast at their facility I mean that
do you think Matt was ready I know Matt
was ready yeah he's been keeping himself
right yeah he has I mean between his
himself not giving up I mean he's not
giving up and I've told him like I think
you should give up so I just tell you
that right there yeah I mean that's all
right but yeah I mean I did I have said
that to him but he is not and between
that and the fact that he coaches all
these kids high school and college
constantly what he's constantly throwing
and doing it and demonstrating so he's
he's full-fledged they know anything yet
I've seen anything they're not gonna do
anything this week I don't believe I
think if something happens it'll be next
week I can say this I know Matt made it
to the final cut well I'm not gonna say
anybody else it was him and two other
quarterbacks who went on to have a
further evaluation who had physicals
right advanced to the first to the
you're going to LA to their home page
can you call for me he they advanced to
that stage yes Matt didn't staying clean
or even joining you in the backcourt
he doesn't frickin come to my house yeah
he doesn't live there so I don't know
what the hell he does I'm actually a get
bitter at him to us sometimes cuz I'm
like he drives to see a friend that
lives past my house and doesn't come to
see me well you know what maybe it's
good he hasn't been in your house yes
now he's good yep alright so hold on is
this like you already know what's gonna
know I have no idea and I'm not even
getting into this conversation with Kyle
like I'm not not at all I don't even
want to talk to Kyle about this or hear
it I don't want any kind of cool though
but hey listen it's always cool when
your little brother has a chance to
continue to live his dream but yeah I'm
not getting involved in this I got you
got to stay away from these things this
is not I'm against the two other guys
that kept going I'm gonna say Tom Savage
mmm
sale Andrew Joe I'll never tell so
online next week on the roster right now
you're all gonna know next week you
think if Matt Simms get signed yes we
will be the first one to break it or
will we get scooped oh no it's only my
brother and one of my best friends we
should give it to somebody else we
should have this the market completely
corn I know the quarterback and the team
a story cuz that's what happens when
you're too good of friends of the people
we're like J blazer I mean it's also
what I fear is if that does happen it's
all gonna be I'm nude of course she gave
it to yes since I mean he's friends with
Chris that's the only reason he's
couldn't it I mean we heard that your
dad would say that yeah quarterback cuz
he sucks and he doesn't know anything
but since his last name Sims we're gonna
bring her in do you think that if when
your dad comes on in about 30 minutes I
say so the doubts that what do you think
the doubters would say if he got signed
do you think he would do that same
impersonation yes this is what happened
to me on Monday night when this all went
down I shouldn't have told you this from
the start I I come in off the back porch
okay yeah I didn't want to do the back
porch for Monday Night Football but I
did too I did I did I've been pretty
strictly yeah week for all my rules
month so I locks for bad I gave up so I
go on the back porch and a lot of the
times they'll literally leave my phone
inside like I'm home yeah and I need a
minute to everybody to back off no
screens I don't need Josh cold good you
selfie for you kitchen feel free to add
your thoughts on the game the good the
good evening tech I did yes so I walk in
the house and Danielle looks at her
phone and goes your dad and Matt called
me and then I look at my phone I go holy
cow
I got like 10 missed calls and it's my
dad and my mat dad in my net dad and
Matt and I'm now my brain has not gone
even close to here something's wrong I'm
thinking my mom is on the way to the
hospital that's what I'm really thinking
I'm going and nobody's texted me
anything
so I'm like what so I call and my dad
like in alike hello there you are oh he
said where you been we've been trying to
call you and I was like I was on the
back patio and he's like oh okay okay
all right
all right okay ah Matt's the 49ers
called and that was like damn I was like
somebody you guys couldn't just text me
that I'm over here having a heart attack
well I texted you are ticked I said no
I'm looking at my phone right now you
did not text me I swear I texted you I
don't know what happened then he didn't
press send in the text but that classic
fail classic felt oh so that's what
happened that was it but I just think I
had a heart attack my big takeaway is
that when sim sees something that's a
little shocking his response is holy cow
holy cow holy cow holy cow Josh is in my
head about my cursing yeah yeah his new
thing is to show me through text what I
should not do here that listener now
sometimes I tell you what you should do
yes show you things on the phone you do
happen yeah that's okay CJ Beathard Nick
Mullens right and Matt Simms
that's what you're thinking that's what
I'm thinking that's your one two three
right there I don't want to go from
something that's fun of something that
I'm annoyed by but you only have to
comment on this Sims tie done whoo we've
had on this podcast before a writer for
Bleach report liked him a lot
had a big article about Blake bortles
and really the whole thing was just
teammates and stuff sticking up for him
and I'm just gonna say that a lot of
stuff coming from the team is it's
unbelievable propaganda I'm just gonna
read a few okay Dede Westbrook Tom
Brady's great but he's been playing
football for a really really long time
who's to say Blake won't be that person
when he puts that many years in so so
here we have a guy saying that Blake
bortles could become Tom Brady then
nathaniel hackett saying to me it's
beautiful
you're gonna adjust you're gonna find a
way to win that's what Blake does he
finds a way to wait to win we were six
in offense last year and Blake touches
the ball every time there was there was
something Keela and Cole had a breakout
first year
wordles put him on the map yeah bortles
taught him how to reach up there with
one hand and catch it that was that was
bortles that really that really
ingrained that into him
Austin Safari and Jenkins says they hate
because they're on the outside they want
to be a part of this they don't know
what's going on the inside which is just
standard football guy quote because
everybody on the outside sucks and
everybody in here is great growing up
this was interesting surprise bortles
was never a quarterback from Pop Warner
to his freshman year of high school he
played linebacker and running back and
when he got to high school they said
play quarterback and he responded why
not but to me the most egregious part
was the Jags were so confident in
bortles last year they decided to take a
knee with the lead at the end of the
first half of the AFC title game I have
been around understand that I have been
around a lot of left Co PR I have been
around a lot of spinning one thing to be
something else but taking the knee
because you're that confident in bortles
when you're two passes away from field
goal range doesn't make any sense
in fact I would say it's a bold-faced
lie all of the compliments in this
article were defensive guys going I mean
he's willing to get hit there's not a
lot of quarterbacks that are willing to
get hit because when I'm judging
quarterbacks I want quarterbacks that
are good at taking sacks that's what I
look for in a quarterback it's egregious
I get it what are they supposed to say
what is Nathaniel Hackett supposed to
say these players I get it but this
propaganda is overwhelming to me it's
we're gonna look at this I thought about
this in bed last night if our tagline is
the podcast that says Rodgers is good
and bortles is bad that's easy I'm fine
with that
hmm I want to be on the right side of
history I just worry about the people
that read these articles and they
believe that [ __ ] I know I don't know
what to say about the subject anymore
you know I think what the thing that
bothers me is people think I'm a hater
right and I just I I don't look at that
that's not being a hater I didn't people
not understand the definition of a hater
a hater is being liked
Tom Brady's not even good Matt Ryan's
not even good LeBron's not even the top
five players in the NBA like that's
being a hater
I know people might not like that I have
Tom Brady is the third best quarterback
of all time or I say Drew Brees isn't
top five but I don't feel like I'm being
a hater there I'm just trying to give it
a realistic evaluation and that's the
same thing that goes in with bortles I
know bortles is a good dude and I do
struggle with that at times but yeah I
don't I don't know what to say about
some of that they're gonna continue to
support that's what I respect about the
jacket I get it was Doug Marrone and and
Tom Coughlin it shows the right way they
are bortles is a good guy and I think
that he's finally like look we're able
to self Scout and talk really positively
about Jared Goff and go wow you know
what he's proving me wrong right bortles
is extremely tough his running is
absolutely a weapon never have we seen
him hit deep fades and shallow crossers
with this kind of accuracy yeah letting
receiver leading receivers with this
offense he's actually executing it
pretty well and that's where I'm gonna
end it I'm not gonna do the butts yeah
that's what he's been doing this year
just just compare him though to all this
other stuff though is none to say that
he could become Tom Brady yeah that's
enough um
let's jump it to your film yeah we're
gonna do 20 minutes then we're gonna
have filled join us you didn't have
notes on this but boy did you have a big
sentence I came out and said I thought
Cam Newton was a top 5 performer at the
quarterback position this year and you
said you know I watched the Panthers
Bengals game and the thing that jumped
out is North turner's running game yeah
what are you seeing happen in Carolina
right well first thing is I don't want
you to think you're wrong about your Cam
Newton thing because he's he's special
and as long as number ones on the field
you have a chance to win and the numbers
can't quantify his value to the football
team they can't because the things you
have to do defense the side of the ball
you just the stats don't always bear out
to what he does but the big thing is the
thing that I like before you get into
running yeah the thing that I like about
cam I'm not seeing the 7
hitch's no I know when I watch Panthers
football there was nothing worse than
him at the end of his drop Pat look Pat
look Pat looks sacked right now it's
drop back look turn fire yeah and it's
it's changed their offense keeps them in
good positions it's a combination of him
and it's a combination of Norv Turner
not calling all 20-yard rounds right or
he's gotten in his brain to when he does
call the 20-yard routes like literally
another day
you have Christian McCaffrey I don't
thank you Sam keep us in second and
seven so talk to us a long game because
you used to always talk about Mike Shula
having a super complex runs right what's
normed yeah norms is an old-school
complex run scheme okay so where Shula I
always liked it because it was a little
bit it gave them an edge as far as like
I want to call it what I call that
college run game stuff the speed sweep
said you know cam gets out on the on the
edge and runs the option with somebody
things like that all that's still there
with nerve but he's brought like 1992
Dallas Cowboys with him too and they're
pulling guards and trapping three
techniques in the middle of the field
and doing things like that where
McCaffrey first of all is a phenomenal
what I would say setup guy for his
blockers he understands how to get
people in the way of his blockers and
then make cuts off them this is what he
did it's Stanford it's so he's Riga now
getting to run in a scheme that he ran
and Stanford Stanford where last year I
would say he's doing inside outside zone
more now he's going oh this is like the
old days with David Shaw coming downhill
there's a guard in front of me and if he
kicks him out I'm going in if he drops
him in I'm going out all of the clips
from Christian McCaffrey's draft tapes
that I would watch would be him kind of
going behind a guard jumping finding a
lane and then boom he's gone yes do you
think Norv did that for Christian
McCaffrey or that's just nerves offense
and it happens to fit well I think it's
I think noir it's nerves offense
and I think when noir probably got the
job he promote like what most guys in
norms position do they go back and watch
some of the players and I was with
Christian McCaffrey only having one year
in the NFL I bet you he went back to the
college days and was like Dan
when he runs behind a fullback and a
pulling guard I mean he makes the right
cut and the right read every single time
can you explain to people what an
inside-outside zone is so that they were
doing last year they're not doing it
right
outside zone is just like okay the
easiest way to explain it is you're five
let's go outside zone you're five
linemen are basically all gonna move to
the right and try to get outside
leverage on the blockers right so
they're gonna beat the defenders to the
side that's holding them back try it now
push them towards the middle of the
field or push them that way and if they
can't actually what we would call reach
block where they can cut them off to the
outside of the part of the ball or legs
out no they'll continue to push them and
they're going oh I can't get them
they'll push them towards the sunlight
and that's he cut back Lane it's on the
running back to find the hole exactly
right like Oh dim that defense end
didn't close his gap because the
defensive tackle on that side he ran so
far to the left side he took himself up
yeah now the tackles way out and that
gap that we talked abouts like ten feet
big so how can you expect anybody to
fill that when you say McCaffrey sets up
defenders to run into blockers right
give me the example right so he you know
traditional like let's say downhill run
game he's I formation behind Cam Newton
he takes two little jabs to the right to
the right like he might go to the right
side but in doing that the backers are
watching him and following him well at
the same time as he's going to the right
the right guard is pulling to the left
and getting Cecily now he's getting set
up to come around and either trap those
linebackers who got stuck inside or
let's say they do get there he's gonna
kick them out but he's very good at
going okay I got it let me kind of I'm
not gonna beat my garden to the hole
so who are running backs that do that
that that do that that have that type of
patience like no no no are the running
backs that hit the hole too fast oh gosh
there's there's a few some times where I
look at it let me just pull up some
names and I'll give you some teams ball
- yeah I just want to say while you're
doing that it is funny because there's
no coach that we roasted this offseason
more than Norv Turner and the amount of
family members that he's brought in
there yes I more than you was even more
vocal because he quit on Zimmer and I
will say that
what he's got blossoming right now in
Carolina without Greg Olson right is
very very interesting right they're
taking on super athletic teams now I
think it's pretty fair that Atlanta's
defense was decimated but the Bengals
were really good and they're finding
ways to get McCaffrey and Funchess the
ball an important situation they are the
true thing is running backs that don't
set up their blockers probably aren't in
the league I was gonna say like your
good ones understand that not all of
them are great as far as running behind
other blockers like I I could say at
times like there was times where Adrian
Peterson wasn't like that like where he
just go I was just gonna let him run
outside zone and let him figure it out
and he'll make something happen with his
unbelievable ability yeah I'm choking on
the spot right here for my heart
question to say who are the bad but
either way either way the point is is
that he is so building telling Romans
that created setting you know he would
there's a there's a perfect guy because
he's a zone runner yes he is that edges
exactly or I'm gonna go 60% yeah thank
you know this years that's a good one
he's I'm gonna run 60% and now I see a
hole and I'm just gonna hit it and fly
through it and actually go through the
hole at a speed that you weren't ready
for and you thought you're gonna get me
and I went through Tevin Coleman hitting
the edge is one of the scariest thing
yeah when you're playing against them he
was about to set some up he will set him
up right he's got a little more that
balance to where he's gonna make you go
oh I'm committing here and he's gone
great commit there that's where I was
never seen actually Tevin Coleman stop
you ride out the guy I've never seen to
have a comb and go and then go it's
always like I'm gonna beat you to the
edge this is fly so yeah he is that but
that run game and then what they're
doing off of it even though they don't
have great weapons in the past game like
we talked about with the like a McVeigh
he always has a package of plays off
these run plays that you look at and go
they're gashing and with this run play
and now he's had five different play
actions with the same thing of the guard
polling and the linebackers are going
damn I don't know if it's the run to the
play-action pass and that's the beauty
of nor bright now because you don't have
notes yeah you leave the game Cincinnati
Carolina feeling what way about the
Bengals
the bangles I think I'm disappointed in
their defense to a degree their front
seven especially to be pushed around
like that is a little like I'm like what
and then really not to get a whole lot
of pressure on cam throughout the day I
think that's what concerns me
yeah how do you decide when you're
watching film if the Panthers o-line
played well or the Bengals front seven
played back yeah that they would be
let's say if they were in some defensive
formations on sets where they weren't
trying to do anything crazy no blitz or
stunts just sometimes you get unlucky
right you go I want the whole defensive
line to slant to the left and they run
and they run a letter or they run left
and smash everybody down there and I was
gonna go damn we got nobody outside like
no there was too many plays where I go
they're set up and they're not doing
anything special and you got this gap
and you got this gap and they got blown
out the Panthers offensive line is one
of the big mysteries it is because I
thought they were gonna be trash in pass
protection I'm still not sold on it but
if he can continue to slow people down
with this run game and then cam is
running as good as I've ever seen him
run and that's where they can be they
can be special Patriots offense Lions
defense okay yeah boy did we think the
Patriots were just gonna dice them up I
had a lot of fantasy players I was
excited to see what was gonna happen but
instead Patricia was the one that had
the advantage not McDaniels you wrote
Patricia
definitely won the battle with Josh
combo coverage dropping people in the
right area didn't need to blitz didn't
need to bliss you're gonna give round
one a Patricia for sure this wasn't just
players now he actually knew what
McDaniels wanted to do he was all over
it and I think the first thing is the
two guys he's got in the middle right
now with a Shawn and DeSean hand in the
middle they do alright shockers they
those two I think they got handle like
the fourth round I don't know because he
had the the leg injury in college but he
was really a top 40 pick and I think
they have gotten a feel for Patricia's
defense and how he wants things done not
being able to be as aggressive upfield
they got to go back to Nick Saban school
and go and now read it stand there be a
man hold these guys up so they are
allowing them not to blitz and then
there
the pocket which is what New England
likes to do to everybody else
Jared Davis is amazing on the back end
but they took no chances they were very
smart they basically said let me see you
run the ball Patriots like we talked
about let me see if you'll stay patient
with it oh you wanted to get into this
power running set where it looks like
you're gonna run the ball well no
England like the Saints I would always
go if they good no sets play the pass
there they're looking to Gashi with the
play-action pass when you do that kind
of stuff and that's where Patricia was
all over it - oh you want to do your
fake fake you know come out of the
play-action fake Gronk over the middle
or receiver runs that slant that's
they're so famous for no they never took
the cheese on that the whole night when
someone figures out the Patriots like
this yeah and it was a former coach
right big ol bleacher report buzzword
did the Lions provide the blueprint for
how to slow down the current Patriots
offense I don't think so
because I just think that you got two
highly intelligent individuals in New
England who will find they're gonna go
damn alright so they played us like this
cuz we might have had these tells and we
do this a lot they're gonna come up with
something else this week to go this is
gonna correct that so people can't over
cover this play and we're gonna find
other ways to cheat and get yards or
whatever it may be
so do they make a game plan fully
expecting the next opponent to try to do
what the Lions did to them and you try
and get them thinking that they're like
copying the line they're gonna make a
game plan based on of course their
history would this defensive coach and
what he does against them and this will
be this is gonna be the Dolphins right
so they're gonna look at things that go
damn this is what they did to us last
year okay we have to change that that's
one category that's in one category and
then they're also gonna look at going
man what if team's been stopping on us
the last few weeks and what are they
doing it's like a self Scout basically
what are they doing to take away some of
our staples so that when Brady gets to
the line and let's say he sees we're out
there with two running backs one tight
end one running by two Titans and I'm
we're seeing the same Lions coverage
they've been working on week on a way to
cut a different play different formation
set that's going to have you ever been
in an organization that goes this is
what we do
and people are stopping it but we just
got to run it harder yeah yeah I mean
Gordon was a little like that at times I
can't say I know I can't I have some
hope for them but I'm just not sure yet
that's kind of my thing with them I
really think you know how we just talked
about the defense getting used to
Patricia I still think the offense is
getting used to this like wait we've
just been like give the ball to Matt
Stafford and we sling it around the
field what are you talking about
managing situations what are you talking
about 1st and 2nd down and run plays
like I really think that's part of Matt
Matt Stafford struggles right now I know
it's this is total gut and this is just
me reading tea leaves and been around
the NFL my whole life but I think right
now he's almost in a little bit of like
I've never been micromanage like this
before I'm actually second-guessing
throwing rifles you know 40 yards down
the field because my coach keeps telling
me Tom never turns it over it's those
things that I think are getting into
Matt Stafford's head he played smart the
other night he made some big throws and
carry on Johnson is good like you saw I
mean he can make the second level guys
and miss a lot he's very quick on his
feet he's got a levee embellish type of
run to him
I was gonna say there is a huge push in
the online community to give all of the
carries to carry on Johnson yeah
especially when I realized that Shawn
Lee is gonna be out uh-huh and we know
how different Dallas defense is when
Shawn Lee is there or not
carry on Johnson could be the guy but
his success rate of running the ball
compared to the other running backs
roster it's not even know it's not he
also looks like a totally different guy
he was a ball it was another guy that I
just got were the leading rusher in the
essence and willing to bet on you right
remember we were saying this during the
draft like he was I I'm not saying he
was Sony Michelle or penny but I thought
he was every bit as good as guys uh you
know I'm a little low on guys compared
to the rest of the world but I think
your point about what you're saying is
if you're the SEC Player of the Year
then damn you're good I don't know what
else to say it's the best conference in
college football it's not even close
coach from the twitter account at
late-round QB among the 43 running backs
with 20 or more carries this year carry
on Johnson is third in success rate
let Garrett blunt is 39 yeah so he's 39
to 43 and carry on Johnson is third yeah
and that's measuring you know what was
available what did you get out of that
was available carry-ons been one of the
best it's time to feed Carrie it is so
that was a good tweet by them Dolphins
Raider so let's get to the YouTube
comments and what they wanted
you wrote dolphins are tough they play
smart case always keeps the big picture
in mind and then I need an explanation
about this you wrote he doesn't let the
players [ __ ] it up right I don't know
what that means
he doesn't like it's third and 17 and
I'm gonna dial up an aggressive play and
trust Ryan Tannehill will not throw it
into a window that's really close and
ruined the whole damn game for us on
that play he just goes yeah I'll find
some cheap way to throw the ball three
yards maybe we can break a tackle and
get the first down if not we're gonna
Pumped it and we're gonna make you
execute and come down on us he's not
gonna let the game be ruined by one Pike
Hall in a tough situation which is smart
he that's is what I respect about him
that he knows looks like him and
Tannehill or they both really understand
I think so what they need to do and how
Tannehill is gonna manage the game I
think so would you call Ryan Tannehill a
game manager I think he's a step above a
game manager you know I do because I
think he can a game manager is a guy
that takes what as offensive coach has
given them and keeps you out of bad
situations and never takes any chances
or anything like that Ryan Tannehill is
a game manager but he can do things
outside the normal realm of the PlayBook
at times whether that's scramble for 30
yards up the sidelines and then his deep
ball throwing you wrote yeah say what
you want
Tanna Hills deep ball is as good as
anyone in the NFL it is on the screws
every time I mean if not every time it's
nine out of ten you know and they take a
few shots every game they got the
weapons and they do got the weapons and
if you even think about it I mean it's
it's every week you know the Jets game
they didn't have to they got to get like
somewhat conservative I think he had one
big pass play in that game but you think
about the Titans game
right they were down bomb down the
middle Malcolm Butler was on Kenny
Stills he just threw it perfectly this
game here
I mean bombs the Kenny Stills and you
know the Akeem grants and all that
that's where I'm impressed so they they
go we're gonna run the ball we're gonna
have you know some high percentage
completion type of pass calls and when I
get a feel for them in the second
quarter cuz I feel like that's about
when it comes every time he starts to
dial up I'll play here and there to go
watch bah blah blah on this route
chicken grant yeah four three eight
right Kenny Stills four three eight whoa
Albert Wilson four four three Kenyan
Drake four four five
Devante Parker four four five Mike
kiseki four five four am Danny Amendola
four five eight Oh Naima fat other than
the Chiefs maybe the Chiefs they might
be faster than the Chiefs jackeen grant
has a level of speed that is Tyree kill
yeah it's not Tyree kill nobody's that
but it's it's ish but it's it's if he
has a lane yeah good bye exactly right
but think about those speeds I know and
and then think about for a tow right
Jarvis Landry okay right how could you
let this guy go what offense did Adam
GaSe run in Denver with Peyton Manning
Wes Welker yeah super slot super quick
quick decisions get the ball in their
hands and then let them go Emmanuel
Sanders Manuel Sanders Demaryius is even
that kind of guy has built a team on
speed Ryan Tannehill can run - yeah
that's the name of the game especially
when you're chasing fast people in Miami
and it's hot right I know I'm just
saying that we just watched a Patriots
defense look too slow against Detroit
I saw last at for my guy Nick Wright
yeah do you know what the Patriots
record Tom Brady's record is at home
against the AFC East in in 28 games and
28 games at home AFC East holy crap it's
gonna be like I'm gonna say 24 and 427
and one are you kidding me the Dolphins
are the only one that
thing Wildcat game with Ronnie Browns
the only home game he's lost on 27 and
one you know right yeah because he lost
the Jets but it was a [ __ ] it was a PI
off game right at home so yeah okay
that's unreal it's only seven and one
right
the Dolphins really have a team yeah
it's a great matchup for them it is side
to side speed which is what the Dolphins
do against a really slow Patriots team
to me we're gonna learn so much about
the Patriots this week we are I am
expecting them to look slow I'm
expecting this to have to be a Tom Brady
figures at on offense and wins in a
shootout but if they're able to somehow
slow down the speed I'll be shocked but
then we'll go here's how they're gonna
do with the rest of the year right
you're good that's what I always worry
about New England like yet New England's
gonna be the lesser physically gifted
team on the field you're a hundred
percent in most games in most games
you're exactly right this definitely
this game and that yeah I the thing I
think will be fun to see is this like if
they just go total if he just goes like
I know gazes offense and we're gonna
take some chances for the first time in
a while and not play this bend don't
break like we're gonna actually take
some crap away I wonder if they'll get
to that point to where he feels like he
has to start doing that that'll be a big
thing I'll be watching you wrote I was
wrong about Micah sickie yes I was wrong
about Micah mean well I just thought he
was soft as baby [ __ ] over in Penn State
no Kiseki
blocks a little better than I gave him
credit for and I do think this goes back
to gates again this is what coaching is
too you know if you if you know the guy
a little bit and you feel like I know
he's got it in him I can bring it at him
I've been them in the meetings of the
combine and we worked out all those kind
of things but yeah between that and then
he's caught the ball a few times it's
like lowered his shoulder and I've been
like damn okay he and slowing down and
he's gonna go make this guy really hit
him and so this is a tough dude man he
is a tough dude yes and then the last
thing before we call your dad I'd shave
him Clara called him a few minutes
lady's gonna be pissed
how much longer will the Raiders trust
Amari Cooper yeah what does that mean it
means that drop balls it means stop
running on a post route when your
quarterback throws the ball over the
first interception when the game is
you're already up like they're already
up there control in the football game
and your Jordy was like 170 receiving
you're exactly right and he throws balls
like that then he drops the ball later
on drops a slant head of something else
where I want to say like he had a missed
assignment but I felt like as the game
went on he finally was just like
martavis is over here I'll look at
martavis I'm talking and I know Gruden
Gruden is the kind of guy that is going
to get annoyed by these mistakes and
these things like this to where also
Amari Cooper's attitude and the way he
is as a person's not gonna lend him to
people giving him the benefit of the
doubt we know it we've seen it we've
been around him he's not exactly the
most charismatic warm feeling guy in the
world and coaches feel that crap too and
if they think you're like this cold
weird dude and then you're not catching
the ball and performing then you do
become this cold weird dude if you're
the guy that's the cold weird dude that
balls are real he's a little weird but
he handles his business huh you're the
cold we are dude is not doing [ __ ]
they're just going he's weird he's
strange I don't know what to say I I
think we have a case of the invasion of
the body snatchers
is there a coincidence that all of a
sudden Calvin Ridley is putting together
a hundred and eighty yard receiving
games and three touchdowns series from
Alabama
I think Saban takes the souls out of
former players then puts them in tuned
future players to just continue to
recycle it was never Amari Cooper
it was the Alabama soul snatcher key
guys didn't like that Phil Simms a call
I mean when have we seen Calvin Ridley
so funny to me yeah I've heard you I
heard you talking about it but it's like
here we have a college receiver that's
so talented and he never got to catch
the ball cuz it's quarterbacks sucker it
was the heart one of the hardest
evaluations of the year was just going
he already looks better than mom's am he
oh yeah he is yeah see he was married
that I called him a middle - yeah right
now
no Muhammad's and there's a middle three
I'm being damned I'm sorry I don't mean
to be that way
Maddie ice though bald last week yes I
need to watch the film more but he is he
is getting to that where I go if you're
gonna be paid like Aaron Rodgers you
have to make some play
like Aaron Rodgers he had some plays in
the redzone and some throws in that game
where I was just like wow oh okay it's
moving I know he's doing a little bit
what we said last year which I like is
this oh here we go big Phil big field
it's big field coming on five minutes
late yeah only for 449 yeah okay as I
said we weren't that bad
see if he answers he's protesting
bothering us
yep I wasn't a great football
conversation with somebody on the phone
get lots of good information news you
know just to help me but now I got to
talk to you too that's alright anything
bad I think what do I call you Anne I
got off the show last week I think I
called y'all something I shouldn't have
done well well that's all right you said
while you were you said that yeah that's
it [ __ ] or something I'm out of here
it's okay dad don't worry you like the
graphic though I sent them the graphic
yes so family so it's okay it's alright
I mean you're allowed to say little
boards like that that's it's not too
crazy of a place and in the NFL locker
room unfortunately that is a word okay
yeah trust me I don't feel proud to say
it I have a little girl I have a little
boy and there isn't word that even my
wife doesn't want my most popular curse
word and a fellow locker room f-word
yeah f-word or I would say [ __ ] next
really it's well you know I grew up in a
different era than Christopher and you
did Adam and I here's one of my favorite
stories of all time I think it was 1988
Wellington Mara the owner of the Giants
who went to church every single day of
his life you know probably every day
every day he know he always went to
church every day Wow and he's never said
much about the team didn't give
interviews 88 training camps coming
Dylan in they go what do you think mr.
Maron i remember the article reading he
goes man our coaches are tough on the
players our players are practicing hard
I love their discipline I love
everything about it
and this and that he goes but I do wish
our coaches could curse just a little
less and
you know they were it was every curse
word you could think started every
sentence you know it was nobody thought
he'd think about it but that's the way
it was back then
the coaches just cursed endlessly and
you know I think there's a lot of staffs
now that I'm sure there's no cursing and
which is kind of hard to do in football
but I know they do it it's impossible I
mean Tony Dungy I'm sure was I mean I'm
out coaching with you know eighth grade
kid throwing a football go you go cow be
careful all right now one more time let
me tell ya all right so Phil take me
take me through Monday night you find
out Maddie boy is getting a workout
what's it like as a dad well Phil
assumes just a dad as a dad I just was
really happy and you know he came in I
was working and sitting in my office he
comes hey I'm going to work out for the
49ers I said oh are you kidding
damn well good for you and this and that
and all that said Christopher you
understand this and Adam I think I go
you want to tour the driveway real quick
[Laughter]
you I want to make sure you're you know
your technique orders he goes I'm good
don't worry I'm good I don't need it I
mean I threw actually actually threw
today okay okay good all right no so
that was that's my first reaction will
go throw a few that's it anyway well it
went really well I'm sure he threw the
ball very well I don't even worry about
that part because I've thrown with my
son a hundred times over the last three
years and I don't remember having one
day going wow man that was not a good
day and he's so yeah he's a machine so
the machine throw on it so that's yeah
what what that gets him well it probably
gonna try out but that's it so it's all
good stuff if there's anybody out there
that's gonna be look of course Matt got
this he kind of knows Kyle and Chris's
friend what would you tell them well go
watch him see it go look at some his
preseason tape and tell him you know
I'll be kind
how's that answer your question mister
don't know nothing make an opinion but
you know you can make a lot of money on
TV not knowing anything and give it an
opinion yes you can I see him next to
every Sunday don't say my opinion okay
let's don't put any facts into it that's
my like I always tell you that's my new
show I'm gonna listen to all the shows
and just go okay
that was a lie that's just total
absolute bull and this is an answer
where I don't know what I'm talking
about but America like I know what I'm
talking about
and with a goal say it really loud and
scream at you there you go
Phil why don't was a lot of people even
you - yeah Phil when was the first time
that you went on a football field and
went damn that guy is a stronger arm
than me Oh Sims your son Chris said it
was Charles Mok no I told him the first
time I ever was worried about anybody
ever throwing harder than me especially
before my sneeze chance mock right yeah
very hard and I mean like really hard
but the problem with his it it's a
football term but the ball was really
heavy it was heavy oh my gosh it was
like a Branden catch it it was so heavy
and you know Aaron Rodgers I saw James
Jones on TV today and they were talking
about he played with Brett Favre or I
think he caught bread at the end of his
career he did right and and somebody
asked him who had a stronger arm Brett
Favre over here in Rogers goes all Aaron
and well how can you say it so quick you
maybe and he goes no I asked players
that have been around but they're you
know with with Brett Favre years before
they said no question Aaron's got a
stronger arm and you know I don't think
there's it's a question now I mean Aaron
Rodgers is you know it's it's it's still
awesome
I mean he's hopping around on one leg
throwing it off balance falling down 40
yards on it with a perfect spiral I
never seen anything like it yeah it is
he actually did move around I think
better against Washington that would
give me hope that he's going to get
better just so we could see
him and to see what the Green Bay
Packers really are well I I don't even
know if I like when your NFL moment what
was the first guy you were on the field
with in pregame or anything like that
were you just like damn I better throw a
little bit holy cow he can throw it you
know we all look at the guy across the
way when he's warming up just to go let
me see how it comes out of his hand what
it is I'm a team I really don't know if
I ever played with anybody on the Giants
that's right their arm than me I don't
think you did
no no I think you know it's a good
feeling to go out there and go okay I'm
gonna throw better than all of you again
today so deal with it
right here we go I was playing the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers my rookie year and I was
watching Doug Williams warm-up on the
other end and I was like oh my god how
did he last - whatever pick he was in
the draft I know why Phil yeah well be -
that's right he played at Grambling and
we got it I know and it's it's a
disgrace how about the throw that
explains him right in Tampa oh I think
it was raining he dropped back slipped
and fell and literally was sitting on
his rear end yes sitting there and threw
an out cut to the left for a touchdown
he did yes yes I mean that was like I
just went that is unbelievable
yeah I know unfortunately for him you
know his body
beat him up his back you know he kind of
had those knees that were a problem and
everything and you know probably just
didn't get his get out of his career
what he really could have if he'd have
been a little more fortunate yeah he
filled it pretty well he won a Super
Bowl and man was he on a roll once he
got in there only I know this if I'd
have been a quarterback with the
Washington Redskins and he was out there
thermally gets me every day I'm thinking
oh my god
we better win I better play well because
you've got to watch it every day and
that's really when they finally just
said let's make the switch so I keep to
leave is on I are ok so he's gonna be
out for 8 weeks 8 weeks ok one of those
surgeries or you'd be 4 to 6 that's what
I thought it was - ok
well I'd be interesting to see I don't
know if it will that's what I said our
team
greatly alright don't ya Chrissa - yeah
in it you know I watched them against
whoever they play in the week before I
can't remember on the Cardinals yeah
well I'm watching them ago oh my god
they got no starters in here they're all
the backups for it's like a preseason
game and then I started to start
watching some of the backups going man
they're good - I know so Wade Phillips
smart coats great coach all ID stuff and
I don't think it's going to be as a big
a factor as we think it is at this time
so Phil your son is like most people in
the media completely fed up with the
body weight issue with quarterbacks
getting hit I feel like if you had that
rule back in the day boy you would have
been called a lot oh yes oh my gosh yes
well you know it's not even that I last
you could throw the ball and the
receiver could catch it and start to
turn up field and start running and then
you still get blasted from behind and
and you know nothing would be called you
know so Phil Phil before you get into
this here's my dilemma this is the
common way in which it is discussed
people go huh if this was back in the
day they'd be able to get away with
anything and it's always this discussion
is there a part of you as a former
quarterback that had to get this Troy -
nothing was called do you look at the
game and you go you know what this is
smarter because man I maybe I should
have been protected more or do you look
at it and go they need to go through
what I went through like no no I don't I
understand it's different there's a lot
of Reggie White's out there now Charles
Haley's and Lawrence Taylor's I mean
maybe not to that great degree but
there's so much speed and you know I've
had this conversation with quarterbacks
in the league and having a beer sit
around four or five and you know I hear
them go man
come on let's Tolkien ourselves it's
life and death back there I mean you
know you got to get rid of that ball as
fast you can and this so and even like
Jean starett or you know he said it - to
me I asked him he goes Phil when you
stand there as an official and you just
see them coming and hitting quarterback
you just go oh my gosh
yeah and so you know when you're down
there in the field and everything it
might carry what he was working with me
he goes you been off the field too long
it's changed these are different guys
rushing to pass for now so I think they
but they're going overboard with the
rule no question when it's blatant call
it and that but I think they I just feel
this way and I listen to you this
morning to Christopher
yeah I think they'll slowly kind of they
don't need to change the role just be a
little more careful when you call it
right in and make it you know like you
said you said egregious but what it's
just you know it yeah in the Clay
Matthews hit is not what I'd go all I
know it and that no that was not he was
to decide a little bit it wasn't driving
him in the ground like they you know it
just it was that was a bad call in my
opinion and I hope they do and I think
they will start being a little more
judicious with these calls and these
hits on the quarterbacks I always have
been robbers burger yes you touched the
helmet that is our automatic and it
always will be but I love the fact that
he just did the old you know I kind of
flopped a little you know this is what's
gonna happen if they're gonna call like
this it's gonna be a new thing to that's
gonna be another unintended consequence
I mean why not try to get it if you can
then oh I always really say that if I
start coming out and practice and have a
special session on how to flop yes 100%
I would I would say oh it's third and 15
man here's we're gonna do you're gonna
hold the ball as long as possible and as
soon as someone's coming you're just
gonna throw it and then you should just
lean into it which of course but what
Phil mentioned is interesting is 1990
and then the average weight of a
defensive lineman may have been like in
the 270's
yeah right so the actual weight of the
defensive lineman since that day has
gone up being a body weight issue
there's a lot of you know you don't you
know what know something but really the
big thing is is the speed when they hit
the last you go down faster so back then
they were still big they just weren't
running for six 40s now it's everyone's
a Lawrence Taylor speed with a Reggie
weight
I mean it's incredible i watch guys
every week i just go well i don't know
how god was that good you know i mean it
do it constantly yeah I'm probably I do
it every week I just killed gosh look at
the speed of some of these guys and it's
and it's what we're seeing and just to
give you an example and Matt Christopher
and I talk about this stuff you know
Adam all the time just the Patriots they
revolutionize or changed football with
the short passing game they did they
changed it everybody started to copy but
what's happened it's now we got to get
away from that why Seattle defense that
scheme people and away from the short
passing because the linebackers nurses
health right they run you over right yes
so the yards after the catch I mean
they're just not what they used to be
like that but these little short
crossers look at and I don't even
consider Detroit a fast team on defense
and New England was so a lot of short
passes and man BAM every ball every
throw is BAM right to the ground right
or and you know then they were they get
there so quick Tom Brady actually missed
some short throws because the closing
speed of linebackers and safeties has
just gotten of course it's faster and
faster well this is the last thing and
we'll let you go just because we're on
this subject and I think it's like you
know I try to explain to people like if
you're gonna make the rules like this
then why would you ever draft a good
defensive pass rusher ever again but
well there's no point in having the 85
Bears defense or the 2013 Seahawks or
the Broncos in 2015 you know like I've
tried to explain to people playing
quarterback and the defense's advantage
on the quarterback is to make him feel
uncomfortable uncomfortable in the
pocket uncomfortable pre-snap
uncomfortable that damn Richard dent is
definitely coming why I'm looking down
the field I'd better throw this thing or
I'm gonna take a sack and he's gonna
kill me and that's part of what the
defense's have and I just think people
are missing that that part of the
conversation well yes there's no doubt
about that and you know there's a couple
things one pressure on the quarterback
is almost and I think sometimes better
than sacking the quarterback
because when there's pressure on the
quarterback that's when you don't see as
clearly the ball doesn't go where you
wanted to go you get turnovers unless
you of course hit the quarterback so
hard he fumbles so but it's still you
know I'm going to talk about the Miami
Dolphins I and I've watched their games
and then I actually looked up numbers
which I usually don't do because I don't
care about the numbers you know I'm not
an analytics guy I go by my eye until
but Cameron Wake and Robert Quinn is
I've watched all three games and you
know they're outside roasters I think
man they're doing a great job of getting
pressure right and then just you know
they're making the quarterback you could
see that they're like I got a throw
right then I look up their numbers and
guess what they got in sacks
yeah like wanita for that one right and
and I just go it's amazing because when
I watch the game I think now they're
gonna have like eight sacks between home
or something like that you know not that
many after three games but yeah but yeah
so they're all over the place it's it's
yet numbers man I say it all the time
they lie so much in football and they
they really live for quarterbacks you
know guys it that really oh you mean
like how you say about his game down in
Jacksonville last week what number do
you put on that Mariota
how about the fact that Ryan Fitzpatrick
has more passing yards in his career
than Troy Aikman okay that's amazing
it is a look these numbers and
Christopher there's one thing I want to
finish answering about all this remember
what's going on and what is it the
league wants more scoring and more
passing yards and they kind of and of
course they want their starting star
quarterbacks to stay healthy that's it
so they're gonna do whatever it takes
and they'll be the happiest when every
game the first one the 40 wins yeah
people can relate to that right they're
not you and me when I'm watching a game
and it's seven to three or ten to seven
I'm going oh I love it
yes can't wait to see the coach that's a
magician up no you know and I like but
the fans just go all boring game they're
both playing terrible well no they're
not right
too busy on insta face it's the pace
well you know the day is coming down but
you just won't be able to do it as great
as even some of these these I look at
Jacksonville as great as they are you
know still some of the rules and just
all the stuff that's going on that they
every rule is almost made for the office
not all there's been a lot for the
defense to but that you can even Lou the
ball give some of these great defenses
now which you could not have done in the
past yeah love you Phil I hope Matt
signs it's going to be awesome now wait
I did like a show last Wednesday very
good thank you to I have to give you a
little credit I'm not just gonna you
know it was cover you're actually kind
of funny yeah that's good that's good
now we're gonna shoot a show here next
week is that right I don't know if it's
the next thing I haven't confirmed that
you are gonna do something at your house
you know I don't worry dude let me know
what the last I'm sorry you're right
I'll get back on that I don't know what
I don't know what the hell they decided
I didn't give you a final answer come
here and you're gonna you know ruin my
day right I'll probably be able to go to
a good game that night which is gonna
really upset me but it look I want you
know let's get some good stuff okay you
know what segment we're shooting at your
house right no we're playing ping pong
you and me on camera no you know we're
gonna do on camera I got boxing gloves
downstairs it says I'll leave Muhammad
Ali
no okay yeah that sounds perfect
[Music]
Phil Simms knocks out producer he does
have Muhammad Ali signed autographed
gloves so be honored to get knocked out
by film it would I would love to do a
quick round and get like one shot on
Phil and he like loses is cool pointed
the pressure thing that's that's the
thing though I mean I just do like
accentuate that point Jacksonville
Jaguars 17th and football and sax okay
the what team are we just talking about
the Miami Dolphins 24th and football and
sex 30 29th is the Los Angeles Rams but
again it is like it's the stat that lies
it's about making the quarterback own
feel uncomfortable and
I'm just I'm surprised to hear your dad
is not an analytics guy I always thought
that he was just gonna be numbers what's
really funny is I feel like he's like he
like looks at the number of sacks as an
analytic like ah that's it guys
that was it good yeah we went over a lot
of your notes on Monday you covered four
or five games on Monday okay I mean is
there anything else you didn't really I
know that you watched Pittsburgh Tampa
and I want to preview the game actually
on Thursday night before we go okay
but Pittsburgh Tampa did anything that
didn't pop out to you on TV pop out to
you on the film I think I don't love
Pittsburgh's defense and what they're
doing I do too little selfies you were
all over their defense yeah I still
question their ability to really confuse
teams in the backend or play sound
coverage all the time the one thing they
got back to in this game was doing some
unconventional stuff I love the Blitz
zone change like Utah heard me talk
about Monday you know oh these two guys
drop out but these two guy blisses is
still a four-man rush but we between dry
it falls back exactly right those kind
of things that's where I felt like they
did in this game and they had a good
feel for some of the concepts the the
Bucs were doing - at least cloud some of
those windows so that would be one thing
I mean I'm not dead on the the Steelers
defense I'm really not I think it's
still got some things you like about it
yeah let's just not forget they played
two out of the three best passing
offenses in football and you think the
Fitzpatrick train keeps rolling i I
don't think it's gonna end he made a lot
of really good football plays I mean he
had some dumb plays - I mean the
interception backed up in his own zone I
don't know what he was he tried to throw
a hook shot to the tight end 30 yards
down the field he had a guy in his way
and he tried to throw a hook shot like
literally windmill his arm and thought
he was gonna still get it there and of
course he didn't
so that was Fitzpatrick ish but I do I
think they're gonna be okay other thing
I don't know we never got into the I
guess the Chiefs defense boyo
so 49ers didn't have a lot of running
successful yeah Breda yeah Chiefs
defense I look at the Chiefs they will
lose a game eventually where the Holmes
has a pick or two or there's a fumble
and then the other team is able to run
the ball
and control the clock most of the game
yes that's the way it looks like how you
beat the Chiefs yeah I think it is the
only way the thing is right now is I
have no feel for the Chiefs defense
right now
how can you they're up 14 like that
exactly right so they never have had a
really play any pressure-packed snaps of
football yet mahomes also i feel like
because that gets the ball back so
quickly I mean they got the ball the
first five times and the game was thirty
five to seven yes I mean so they get to
play at a luxury but they are dangerous
and they can be unconventional too they
are not a real good defense but they do
have playmakers at key areas I think
that can be interesting there and also
on third down that would be the other
thing Bob Sutton on third down if they
get you there then they got you its
first and second that are the issue why
I third down he'll do some crazy stuff
and it's obvious passing down and I
think it confuses the quarterbacks first
and second down they can blow coverages
Kyle exposed their run fits a few times
and the run games change the formation
on them and all sudden ego Dan that
safety was rolled over here but they
went in motion now they rolled to safety
the other way well nobody's got this run
gap over here what the hell we doing I
got it so it was little things that like
that that came up in the game not sold
of them but would that the way this way
they play football they should never be
this sound been don't break defense they
should attack all the time I make chance
as you're all back to the exact way if
you're in a close game don't sit there
and be like oh we're gonna Bend a bro
break and keep our offense off the field
for 15 minutes no let's do something
make a play or they get score a
touchdown and you give the ball back to
my home because I have more faith in the
home scoring consists their best defense
right now right and then the other thing
is the Niners they went winless with CJ
Beathard last year yeah is that what
we're expecting going forward I mean I
would expect him to be better than last
year I do think their offensive lines
better to where they can dominate
running football games that way but yeah
I mean I'm concerned I mean I'm gonna
have a hard time picking them to beat
the Chargers this weekend I don't see
any no way I mean it'd be have to be
Kyle magic time this Thursday Night
Football is Andrew Whitworth a hundred
percent out
I don't know I think he I want to say he
is he's not he did not that was total he
do he wrote news to me fam so that
injury wasn't the dollar jury wasn't
real it wasn't really he said I was
getting a massage I believe if I
remember that correctly right broke that
and I know but to leave Peters out Rams
looking like the best full team in the
sport right now
yeah good offensive line offense is
attacking I feel like they're they're
getting the ball down the field in like
four plays yeah defense without the
corners you and your dad surprisingly
think they're gonna be fine yeah not as
good but they're gonna soda goes out
there lays an egg against Buffalo of the
week before they needed a miracle
fourth-quarter from Kirk Cousins to come
back but he was very impressive and the
week before that they had a lead over
the Niners but they couldn't put him
away the questions about the Vikings no
Everson Griffin Pat F line is back at
center but even he wasn't that good in
his rookie year the interior offensive
line is an issue for Minnesota but a lot
of people are going digs feelin should
have a big game on a Rams defense that
doesn't have their starting corners how
do you see this game kind of fleshing
out Zimmer has come out and says great
short week and you're making us fly
across the country really appreciate
yeah we have yet to see an away team win
on Thursday Night Football
granted we saw the Baker Mayfield
experience last week yeah how do you see
this one playing out Cousins did not
play well last week forget the fumbles
he missed them throws he was off last
night last week so that worries me a
little I don't think they're gonna put
the Rams are gonna put their corners in
position a whole lot that they're gonna
have to man up on them throughout the
game at least on a consistent basis I'm
not sold on the D Philip offense yet I'm
not I think it has some like what is the
de Filippis it's West Coast at its base
right here's I would say a little bit
more of a knock bass offense and let's
say I'm Mike McCarthy or a doubt Darrell
Bevell I used to get on up compared all
the Eagles offense which is where he
came from less yeah it's not quite as
creative as the Eagles it's like a dumb
down Eagles version we're not a quite as
the aggressive passing concepts I think
that the Eagles have or have the
capability of drawing
right so I look at it like that like it
may have gone more with Frank Reich so
right so I look at this with D filippo
and go man I'm not quite sure about it
yet I certainly were even the L vine
back that interior part of their D line
we don't know if to having cooks can
apply either right we're probably gonna
start latavius Murray and damned if I'm
the Rams without no Everson Griffin and
they the Vikings like to play the same
11 people pretty much on the field the
whole game damn I'm gonna hurry hurry
I'm definitely doing that to them I mean
they should be a well-oiled machine as
you saw in the the our show we switched
from alley to Ira IRF you're listening
good luck he went with Minnesota plus
six and a half you said on the show
you're definitely going Rams you're
definitely going around I'm definitely
going Rams I see this a lot it's just
scary but I do I think they're in a
class of their own right now I really do
and I just the mad scientist is he's on
a tear he's found he's cracked the code
every week like instantly to where
you're like damn it's the fourth play
and he knows everything they're doing
from a coaching perspective are you more
likely to go with the coach and Zimmer
who knows who they are and sticks to
that on a short week or the guy that
typically takes the whole week to draw
some stuff up yeah it definitely hurts
McVeigh more that's what I think I think
the short week always helps the lesser
town the lesser coach yeah right I do
think it hurts them I think they have
enough in their offense though that it's
gonna really annoy Zimmer to to where
he's gonna be scared to do certain
things you know damn if they run this
play and I bring that blitz they can
really hurt me it doesn't sound like
you're gonna question the Rams at all
like it sounds like really anyone in
this spot you were gonna feel pretty
confident in the Rams yeah yes I feel
pretty confident in the Rams right I
think the Rams are like I said I'm not
backing away from my Jaguars thing
either I still think the Rams and the
Jaguars is the two best teams in
football you know it's a lots gonna
depend on number five down in
Jacksonville if number five in
Jacksonville could just have thrown the
ball at a a virile for an NFL
quarterback last week they would have
won that game and I'm not trying to be a
jerk I'm just telling you they would
have won the game but there was plays
that were there to be had that were left
out there and that's why they lost 96
mm-hmm awesome all right
so I'm not even gonna try and make any
pics that's for them don't do it wait
for tomorrow yes yeah all right so that
was Phil Simms joining us we broke down
some games and enjoy the story of what
Matt Simms is really going through right
now
I really hope he gets signed if he gets
signed I feel like we should buy his
Jersey and put it up yeah I think you're
right right yeah Sims Niners Jersey
right that's what your dad should have
been with Bill Walsh gosh I just need a
living off his Super Bowl money you get
us this freaking news news yeah the Matt
Sims news you want to burst your twitter
account
you haven't tweeted in over a year yes
by Brooks of Miami sends a left go
Twitter account but all right I will
actually say something to them that I
want to break this if this does happen
good yeah be awesome yeah all right four
six he's out homie the news break for
fender good evening everybody
and the lef koe man we'll see you guys
eat that Josh
[Music]
you